[Intro music]
The team of creators of Psych2Go
would like to recognize and praise
the overwhelming support
and sense of community
that we have seen among our viewers.
On previous videos,
many brave viewers have
shared their own experiences
with mental illness
or abusive relationships,
and have been met with kind words
and advice from others.
We hope to encourage a safe
and supportive environment for all.
And we would like to thanks our viewers
for making this possible.
We hope to see
a similar response to this video,
7 ways to deal with
abusive parents.
1. Contact a resource.
The National Domestic Violence Hotline
is available to anyone
at 1-800-799-7233.
There are always
local resources you can find
by means of a quick phone call
or internet search.
And in an emergency however,
always call 911.
We'll include several helpful resources
in the description box below!
2. Talk to someone.
Whether you're wanting an intervention
or simply someone to lend an ear,
talking to a counselor, therapist
or even a friend can help.
Someone else can
help you find resources
if you're unable to.
Or they can be there
to cheer you on in rough times.
3. Find a safe space.
If you feel in any way unsafe
or uncomfortable at home,
look out for other places
where you do feel safe and sane.
Keep these places in mind
when you need a moment to yourself
and consider if these are places
you can go in an urgent situation.
4. Don't blame yourself.
No matter what your parent may say
or try to show you,
their behavior is not your fault.
Abusing a child is never okay
under any circumstances,
no matter how much
the child may misbehave
or provoke their parents.
You deserve every bit of help you can get.
So please don't be afraid
to ask for it.
5. Keep a journal.
It's not uncommon
to unconsciously block out
or forget traumatic moments in the past.
So it may be helpful
to make a journal
of all incidents, thoughts,
and feelings you have.
Journaling may also be a helpful
emotional release for you,
and it's up to you whether you share your writing or not.
6. Don't provoke your parent.
When possible, it is in
everyone's best interest
to avoid abusive and violent situations.
If certain behaviors tend
to provoke an abusive parent,
try to avoid these triggers if you can.
7. Trust yourself.
If you don't feel safe,
it is okay to leave the situation.
Go to your safe space
or contact one of your friends
in your circle of support.
Trust your guts instincts
when it comes to reading
possibly abusive situations.
Remember that
your safety comes first.
We would like
to thanks our sponsor,
BetterHelp,
for making online counseling
affordable and available.
We've attached a link to BetterHelp
in the description box below
for anyone who might be interested.
Online counseling is a great way
to get yourself the help you need,
even if you aren't ready
to see anyone in person.
This comment section is a safe space
to share questions, reactions,
story or advice.
Please be supportive
and respectful of others.
Thanks for watching!